if your brother listen to the first one
yeah and thought would he say he learned
nothing nothing and too much too much
how'd we do I think we hit it again uh I
don't know it just feels I'm not sure
um okay you guys are the best and
they're encouraging us I don't know if
that's true
but I'll take your word for it I mean
it's gone but you thought your life
would oh it was almost over right how
long have we been talking just under an
hour just under an hour yeah and then
the ads and there's three are three
what's that 35 minutes worth of ads no
are you doing the 10 minute Preamble
thing is that what you call it yeah we
don't call it the Preamble what do you
call it the intro it's a 10 minute intro
I think so yeah I really don't know much
about the podcast I I've listened to the
podcast and I just know that at least
once you just did away with the intro
yeah occasionally because because it was
such a special occasion yeah this isn't
going to be one of those is it we'll
have three intross
let's take a little break
you know what
are you when we're done just I'd like to
record a 10 minute intro as well
I'd like to do an intro before your
intro that's a great idea I love that
yeah sure let's do that yeah are you
serious let's do it no no I think that's
a really funny idea I do we can do it
right now
if you're up for it yeah let's do it all
right well let's end this one yeah let's
end this that's a good idea
um
Tim are we going out to dinner tonight
I'm up I'm I'm available I'm around
are you uh are you backing out no I'm
not back tomorrow's also good if that's
better for you because you might be jet
lagged no I'm not jet lag are you coming
downtown because I'm told because I came
to your city now I came Uptown for this
so I assume you kind of I've heard the
Hard Rock Cafe is a cool spot the one
downtown very cool okay
sometimes I get to eat an okay hamburger
near a guitar you know what I'm happy
sad is now that I've agreed to do an
intro
I realize how difficult your job is no
you're gonna kill it oh really yeah so
it's just Adam and I are just shooting
the what is it I don't know you've
had this idea and now you have time yeah
but you have like it doesn't have to be
10 minutes it could be a quick intro not
even usually a part of it that's that's
my point but he you're talking to your
where are they I'm gonna leave the room
right now no where are they they there's
usually someone you're talking yeah
so they're not here yet they're not in
town yet what do you mean they're not in
town yet they're not here yet but
they're coming yeah I gotta come back to
do the intro I don't think you can just
do it solo yeah you can do it solo I'm
gonna do uh solo yeah okay you could
just say I mean the premise is really
funny I like the whole premise is
I know I listen to the podcast I was
always an intro and yeah and I just
wanted to have an intro before Conan's
intro yeah because I feel like I've
earned that whatever you'll you'll kill
it that yeah
okay all right I'm gonna I'm gonna get
out okay cool you are my friend for real
you know that right I do know there's no
backing out now I know that's true we're
going out you're hanging out you got
another interview after I have a I have
a meeting after this and then
um this is all fun stuff for the
listener
and then uh this actually probably is
this might be better than just uh I'm
going yeah so what do you got after this
I've got a meeting with the guy that
runs uh Sirius what does that mean
exactly I don't know keep this wrong
this is good
what actually happened I think they're
letting me go no but before we even they
they're gonna just say hey things are
going no no we haven't even launched yet
so there's nothing our Serious Channel
hasn't launched I think it's just gonna
be uh hey man good to see you meeting I
hope oh really thanks for doing this
appreciate you being a part of it yeah
this is okay I didn't know this was I
okay so that's cool so you got that
going for you how long is that how long
did you have that meeting going for me
yeah that's a big deal I love that you
still have to do meetings I'm going to a
meeting right after
is this one of those things this is me
and you talking this is pretty much by
the way guys this is dinner listen do
you do that because you're a good dude
or you do it because what's in it for
you why you mean with this knucklehead
well first of all
um he runs all of serious so what and uh
he said hey can Conan stop by and say hi
uh you know before he leaves for the day
okay and I hear that and being a nice
human being I'd like to see him no it
also what if he tells me something what
if he says Hey Conan you know Ryan
you've done so much for serious we're
all so excited to have you here's a gold
bar that I want you to have maybe that
happens in the meeting and he gives me a
solid gold bar okay I'll meet you I'll
see you at dinner and you bring show it
to me because I want to see it I'll show
it to you I can't wait to hear the song
follow-up of this meeting it's because I
I'm guaranteeing it's like there's five
minutes I cannot get back
okay so you
mean that's not a meeting you just kind
of made it sound more important than it
needed to say and what's after that
that's when you and I go to dinner we
can do it early how are you getting down
I'm downtown you're gonna come downtown
sure take the subway
I yeah I'm no stranger to the subway
that's it what's it what's uh because
here's the deal since we've become
friends I meet people
who who would be like hey don't say
something nice and then they'll be like
hey say hi to Conan
right because we are famously Pals so
much so it makes me so happy
is bitter about it and shouted at me you
have your dinners with Timothy Oliphant
unbelievable